coming back to the main topic of why we
even got on this thing why do you think
people are lonely
see again like it's a lot of it and this
is probably the worst way I can say it
but I think it's all just perspective
based right like I think there's
obviously a lot of issues that we've so
far discussed in this very deep podcast
episode about like you know what might
be the reasons for it but I think
there's a lot of uh instances where I
think people say they are lonely because
they just feel that way and there is no
concrete reason as to why that is maybe
it's based on their life experiences of
like all like their ideology of what
being lonely might actually mean to them
and then you know obviously there are
many businesses where it's just
something that's out of the control like
the pandemic or are you saying that you
think
people aren't less learning them before
but their perspective makes them think
they are more money maybe that might be
the case because I feel like you know
especially in this day of uh social
media like people are more connected
than ever before and it's so much easier
to connect with people whether that be
online or IRL right so maybe this
environment of everyone is connected
with everyone at all times through
social media has kind of like raised the
bar of what is considered loneliness
perhaps or maybe lower the bar I I think
I disagree I think also I'm just trying
to I I I it's the words you said yeah
I'm processing I'm hearing the words and
I think I just yeah I I'm pretty sure I
disagree it's a really tough topic to
like you know get a full concrete yeah I
think on like a I I just I think people
are lonelier and it's not like a
perspective thing I think people just
are lonelier and I I don't think it's
like because people
think they're more lonely or whatever I
think people actually just are more
lonely right
um again this is all opinion oh yeah
this is like almost I mean this is just
based off like there's no right or wrong
a lot of a lot of questionnaires
whatever polls and stuff and you know uh
suicide rates are up as well and people
are just I think factually just more
lonely
um what that stems from I think is just
from like a million different issues
being yeah broken down and like feeding
into each other and the pandemic was
like all right let's raise this to yeah
yeah yeah yeah I'm sure the pandemic
like did a lot yeah people realize a lot
of things
um and I you know I just think there's
there's always just been this less
emphasis on being social and uh just
because I think that we've been afforded
more luxuries that allow us to be less
social and it's easy to adopt like you
know more technology that allows us to
be less social and we didn't really
think like is this going to impact us at
all no it's more convenient let's just
do it yeah
um and then you have
countries like Japan where they're like
hey well we've been lonely for a while
so let's just let's just make a solution
that you can pay for like let's just go
to you can pay to go out like you can
pay to go and hang out people you can
yeah you can hire people to hang out
with you you can go to a bar and pay
people to talk to you it's like and it's
like this really weird kind of like
let's not worry about why people are
lonely let's just let's just throw the
solution yeah yeah and let's not address
that's not like get to the root of the
problem yeah which is like which I think
when we're talking about loneliness in
our perspective we're talking about it
from a western perspective of loneliness
um right which is why I'm kind of
curious to be like I wonder how much
worse it is because it's probably a lot
worse in Japan like in terms of like the
rate yeah I think that it's also
important when we talk about it like
that is to think about where that
loneliness comes from and I think why
Japan is lonely is like a mixture of why
a lot of people in the Western countries
think they're lonely combined with the
horrible worth worth yes life balance in
Japan yeah that also comes back from
from even like school life where you're
kind of robbed of a lot of your free
time I think I think it's like are the
reasons why these two countries are
lonelier like inherently different but
also then technology is like fueling the
Flames of it's [__] enough for
everyone yeah yeah and I'm not this is
not like a doomerism of me being like
man technology bad I just think it's
like it's impossible to adopt all this
technology and not think hey how is this
affecting us because we're just too busy
being like let's [__] let's use it
well let's just [__] adapt it let's
put it in let's [__] [__] this all
let's do some calls all the time yeah
you know I mean I think you know it's
the meme is like oh look Boomer say
technology bad haha live a laugh at him
the reasons why this is technology was
bad was totally different to why yeah I
think it actually is bad yeah yeah right
like they're saying because they were
just like I don't understand it well I I
do I do feel that you know it's not
technology isn't inherently the bad
thing the bad thing is our self-control
we're not able to adapt yeah is our own
self-control right uh because it's it's
not like social media's fault in per se
you know social media is just a platform
you know
um but you know being addicted to social
media being addicted to you know having
having what is their fault yeah having
having these tools that are available to
us to combat the loneliness without
actually combating the loneliness but
like like tricking our brain to making
us feel a little less lonely without
actually having like you know maybe
giving us uh maybe uh maybe Arsenal
actually going our way to find a real
human connection that's that's part of
like partly on us to be like we are too
lazy um yeah I mean I feel putting the
effort in too many people are like
blaming the tool and not the user yes I
don't know I I that's kind of tough
because I think that a lot of these
platforms use way more data than than
they ever should have to perfectly
engineer solutions that like hack our
brains to keep us glued yeah right and
in a way that maybe if you had if it was
present in a different way you might not
be as in as uh addicted to it it's like
you know do you no so yeah what I'm
saying is I'm not trying to blame the
user what I'm saying is you need to be
like aware of this you know there needs
to be more Consciousness about this
thing because we actually we actually
see it like the amount of like you know
I'm aware that like that it's addictive
and it's still addictive like I can't
it's not stopping me from being addicted
okay you know you're addicted but like I
see like I think the worst case I see
with it which is ironic which is like
when parents get really addicted to
social media and like websites it's
actually like I feel like it's like 10
times worse than when like people our
age or younger people getting into
social media because what I've seen
parents addicted they are they it's it's
like they don't even know it's a problem
you know yeah like you know some you see
some parents that are on Facebook all
the time and they have changed literally
changed their viewpoints based on like
some [__] articles that they see on
Facebook book and they get like I've
seen like now families literally get
divided because of some [__] Facebook
posts that people make well yeah well
that's like I mean that is like I think
the social media's fault because they
were you know they they knew that
posting outrageous [__] and they would
they would help bump it because they
were like oh this this drives engagement
yeah and people engaged something with
most when they're pissed off yeah so
let's keep fueling this [__] up [__]
and let's keep pushing in front of
people and yeah not everyone is you know
and it's I think it's their fault I
think some people are just more
susceptible to
stuff that is just inherently like wrong
or
that you know like fake fake news and
[__] I get not to get into all of it I
think people legit are more susceptible
say oh a lot of people who are more
susceptible to that than others yeah and
a lot of these social media platforms
weaponize that to drive engagement yeah
because they also probably realize that
if you get someone to be super engaged
with the topic oh like the flickering if
you get someone to be super engaged with
the topic they'll push more about it
they'll be on the platform more looking
more interacting more and then so it's
like this kind of really like
self-fulfilling prophecy of like just
kind of vile behavior that they're kind
of getting people hooked and keeping
them in with all this [__] and
connecting them then to other people
who've also been fed the [__] as
well and they're all spreading it as
well yeah yeah yeah so yeah to get back
to your original question sorry I I do
like you know I said this earlier but I
do think just because there are more
tools available right now that trick you
into thinking you're not as lonely uh as
you actually are yeah when you're not
actually forming the connection to
actually combat the learning that's yeah
at its core and that's what I think
that's that's what I think and then a
double A double-pronged attack on that
is that let's say you you uh you feel
lonely and you recognize you feel lonely
from from maybe not being have that
connection uh you know a lot of the time
what do we turn to when we want to try
and make those connections we go online
yeah and I think a lot of these there's
a lot of websites or a lot of
um people kind of prey on that
loneliness then offer them a solution
online be it you know you're lonely
romantically his dating websites yeah
where you might get connected with
catfishes or people trying to scam you
or you know all weaponizing Learners
yeah God knows what the nice loneliness
it's like how
Tinder would Tinder forever I believe it
still does this I I'm not sure but
Tinder at one point in time and again it
could still be doing this
um you know if you were an older male
who uh was maybe less attractive you
would be charged more for Tinder gold or
plus whatever are you serious yeah you
could charge way more money
um [__] hell and then they they you
can you can look this up Kai but they
were basically they were basically like
depending on how in demand your profile
was you'd be charged a different amount
yeah and you know then they would be
like oh you're not getting matched as
much you know there's this thing called
a super like you know or uh there's a
you could you could pay at one point on
Tinder to be the top profile right two
hours which then they'd be like we
promise you more matches it's only it's
only 30 bucks to do this you know but
you might meet the love of your life
what's 30 bucks you know yeah so they
would kind of weaponize your loneliness
and and I think that
not blaming the platforms is I I [__]
I fully blame the platforms for the the
predatory behavior they get they got
away with doing like they tender should
have never ever been able to do that
like the fact that they were able to
charge you more because you use the data
to then weaponize and target people who
they knew were lonely and who were
desperate yeah and be like hey I know
you're lonely and desperate and you're
ugly as [__] no one wants to love you
uh and you're never gonna get married or
find someone because
pay to win yeah but if you pay us 100
bucks a month and on top of that you
know it's still not enough you know you
can do this [__]
more expensive
yeah so it was more expensive people who
were undesirable wow um ageist
I fell off man and that's like a really
like that's an obnoxious kind of look at
what they're doing right that's an easy
thing to point to but I think I think
that a lot of the platforms are doing
stuff like this where they are targeting
people who they know are more lonely and
more likely to spend or more likely to
give them screen time uh and then they
they use that and I think that's
something that is like something that is
just so hard to address that
is very hard to and that in a political
sense it's also really hard to get like
get any meaningful change done because
they also hold a lot of power and we
also rely on these platforms a lot yeah
and it's you know it's like if you're
Googling how to make friends you know
Google then starts serving you ads about
hey meetups near you just pay ten
dollars to join the platform or stuff
like that and it's like monetizers yeah
or maybe you know
it's like you get targeted on Instagram
by fake accounts from like catfishes
like obviously that's like the lowest
and low and there's hardly anything
sophisticated but yeah you know there's
just people are always willing to take
advantage of you and that's that's like
a [__] place right now that just
didn't happen before like my my [__]
parents didn't have to worry about
someone trying to [__] sign up to a
dating website and charge them [__] [__]
ton of money or didn't have to worry
about if they had enough friends it was
like no you should make friends you know
there's so many friends you could make
and you have to worry about being
catfished or this kind of [__] yeah you
know what I mean like there's just so
much weird [__] that we we're so quick
to like sweep under the rug and not
address because it maybe doesn't apply
to us uh and I I don't know it's very
frustrating because I think that God how
did Boomers do it people lose empathy
people lose so much empathy towards
other people when they're when they're
in a good position yeah for sure it's so
easy for you when you have friends to
blame people who don't have friends like
you blame them be like no no you're
you're completely at fault for not
having friends it's like maybe you
weren't set up right and then maybe
maybe you were given no chance in life
to make friends and you were never given
a good chance uh from your you know your
parents set you up to fail and then on
top of that everyone's taking advantage
of you and and then maybe the people who
were in place to help you just failed
you in every way you know maybe your
people like teachers or people who
should have been there to be able to
help you if you failed you and I think
there's a lot of I it's just frustrating
that people aren't empathetic towards uh
towards that you know and it's easy to
sensationalize people who are who are
[__] up and who have caused their own
problems like look at these guys they're
causing everything wrong in their own
life yeah everyone else must be like
yeah yeah right yeah we demonize people
a lot because we we like I think people
who um are doing well you know like
we're doing well it's very easy to be
like well we did it it's All Odds just
make friends I mean that's we've solved
all of our own problems okay and it's
such a bag of like it's so tough because
I do think that we
as individuals we are very proactive and
we have definitely taken opportunities
to to try and give ourselves the best
chances yes but also we were very lucky
in a lot of Senses as well I think okay
but I guess you're you're like no no
you're you're making like such great
points uh there's so much like I could
throw at this and it's like I think
about this stuff a lot and it's yeah
it's so hard because it's so hard to
determine what's okay tangential and
what's important for me for me it's less
of uh yeah for me it's for me it's still
okay so my kind of like this is like
just like my personal philosophy right
for me it's less of a haha look at all
these people they're not oh they're
obviously not putting in yeah like
effort in you know you know you know
obviously technology companies like you
said are definitely predatory especially
when it comes to just hacking our
[__] brain oh yeah yeah what I'm
trying to like what my approach to
pretty much everything in life is is
um I can only control what I can control
which is like myself so my my kind of a
whole philosophy is less of like
uh when when I have a problem in my life
you know
um I kind of I kind of try to approach a
problem of what can I do to change
myself because I can't guarantee that I
can change the world to fit into like my
boundaries but
everyone is yeah everyone is born with
different circumstances with different
like advantages disadvantages uh and you
can't always control that so my personal
philosophy has always been what can I
control in my life to make my life and
myself the best person and version it
can be that's that's the monk in you I
know I don't know because I agree with
you no I totally agree though yeah yeah
so yeah so I'm not trying to say like oh
don't blame the technology companies or
don't blame this don't blame that don't
blame this I'm just like okay if I was
in some other person's shoes this would
be my approach to it because I can't I
can't change the way that Twitter or
Facebook promote their [__] I can't
control the way that they try to hack
your attention and do all this but I can
try to control myself if I want to make
if I'm feeling lonely then what can I do
about it I can put my I can try to put
myself in a situation where I can be
more social hopefully make more friends
down the line that comes as a bonus but
the first step to me will always start
with me yeah I think that speaks to your
upbringing though like I think your
parents distilled a lot of really like
good values indeed because I just think
a lot of people just don't they just
don't see the world that way right yeah
I think I feel like yeah for a lot of
people that kind of like disciplinary uh
you know like self-care uh that you know
they the beliefs that you have is not as
naturally integrated into people as
other people right and it's like I feel
that's a skill that you either have to
have grown up with or you just have to
have like realized from a young age yeah
because because especially with the
internet when we're talking about like
complex situations like this there will
always be that side where someone is
genuine only
um in a bad position they've been [__]
over in life and they've been [__]
over by those people around them and
then sometimes you see on the internet
where you there's definitely someone
with like a victim complex oh for sure
like 100 yeah yeah yeah yeah you know
it's it's hard to like just distinguish
sometimes on the internet just because
no matter what the internet has made us
been able to connect with every kind of
person from every Walk of Life so my My
Philosophy with all of this and my
advice has always just been the first
step is just focus on yourself because
you cannot especially with the internet
with the scale we're working with now
you cannot everyone's in a different
situation you can't you can't have a one
or solution for everyone you can't
change the algorithm on the screen but
you can change the algorithm up here
that's that's it baby that's what it is
that's what it's all about that's what
it's all about facts
no for sure yeah yeah I I think it's
just always the main main thing I was
trying to get to is just yeah you know
it's always just really important to
never lose that end but
online allows us often to just cut that
off we don't want to deal with it if you
don't want to be empathetic towards
other people sympathetic anyway I think
it's too easy to fall into that and uh
yeah just don't yeah
empathy empathy is a thing that is uh
losing more and more yeah value as time
goes on yeah it feels like
a lot of the social climate that we're
in right now is like weaponizing the
lack of empathy against people to to you
know to kind of incentivize some uh to
kind of benefit a certain group people
it's like well don't don't worry about
them because they they do it themselves
you know we we did everything right you
know we're good don't don't worry about
them like yeah Spread spread any [__]
lies you want and also like people just
do it for like their own kind of selfish
self-satisfaction right yeah of course
yeah it's like ah well well I mean
that's your guys's problem that's not my
problem I don't give a [__] about that
you know you can deal with that I'm
gonna live life in my own way right
which is like it's yeah it's pretty
[__] selfish like unfortunately
there's a lot of people nowadays who do
think that way because they're like well
I don't I'm already dealing with [__] in
my life yeah I don't have time to deal
with [__] in other people's lives it's
like well I mean you can technically
yeah as the goat once said you have no
enemies
that's it that's it that's such a good
Mantra though [__]
sure it's true man that is true that is
just my life man I'm so glad that became
a meme if there's anything from Finland
song
Right [__] who have no enemies
man that's that's what the internet
needs right now man that's probably like
my favorite meme that's come out in like
the past year it's so good